we've been expecting the iPhone 9 the
20/20 iPad pro in other Apple products
to get announced at Apple's annual March
event where Apple usually has new
product releases
however the coronavirus has other plans
I'll explain in just a minute
last year Apple sent out invitations to
their March event on March 11th and now
on march 13th 2020 finally made an
official announcement but not for what
we were expecting
yep they announced their annual WWDC
conference and there are some major
changes this year in the words of Phil
Schiller himself Apple is delivering
WWDC this June as an online experience
for the first time ever that means no
live audience
no hands-on sessions with new products
and no live presentations for developers
everything is happening online so with
that said what does this all mean well
first of all since they didn't
acknowledge their March event a single
time this means that if they were in
fact planning to have a March event it
is now 100% confirmed that it is not
happening this means that any new
hardware releases that Apple was
planning to launch this month including
the iPhone 9 and 20/20 iPad pro are
going to be delayed until their WWDC
event in June yes that means we have to
wait another couple of months for those
product releases and this isn't just my
own personal speculation based on my
opinion check out this quote from Craig
federighi when Apple announced that WWDC
2020 is happening online with all the
new products and technologies we've been
working on WWDC 2020 is going to be big
with Craig adding in that extra little
bit of info Apple is hinting that WWDC
is going to be packing more
announcements and product launches than
usual which most likely includes those
products that were meant to be launched
at their March event so of course we all
know why it happened and that's the
corona virus pandemic Phil Schiller
admitted it himself mentioning that the
current health situation has required
Apple to create a new online WWDC
twenty20 format so now that we know why
it happened let's get into the details
of what went so wrong that
was forced to delay these releases when
the coronavirus broke out in China most
of the factories were completely shut
down right as Apple was going full speed
ahead with the production of iPhone 9
and other new products that means that
the required parts for assembly were not
being manufactured for weeks during
those shutdowns causing supply shortages
and slowdowns it was so bad that
Bloomberg reported that Apple stores are
facing shortages of current iphone parts
and replacements due to the corona virus
there are even rumors that the iPhone 12
meant to launch in September could be
delayed as well yep that's how serious
this is
this is gonna be very bad for Apple
sales and profits this year and this
isn't just affecting Apple everyone is
getting hit including Samsung which
unfortunately released their new S 20
line right before the coronavirus
started getting more serious they even
made a statement blaming much lower
sales of their s 20 phones on the
coronavirus and with the S 20 ultra
being priced at a mass of $1400 not as
many people are gonna be buying in when
there is so much uncertainty over the
world economy during this pandemic there
are already huge numbers of people
getting laid off due to the corona virus
and some are saying that this is just
the beginning with the economy going
down a lot of businesses are starting to
struggle especially ones that sell
expensive luxury devices that people
obviously don't need to survive so for
that reason Apple and many other tech
companies are in trouble and because
less people are buying smart phones and
tech devices there are going to be less
people watching youtube videos trying to
figure out which tech devices to buy
leading to a drop in viewership on many
tech focused YouTube channels like this
one so from all of the tech channels on
YouTube we want to ask you guys to keep
watching videos from your favorite tech
channels and of course other channels
that you enjoy watching to help support
us and help us get through these tough
times as well so with that hopefully you
learn something new from this video and
if you did feel free to click that
circle above to subscribe and check out
the type of tech videos that we make
right over there right here at max tech
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]